hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and in the previous video
you could see us building a roof for our
pizza so we now have a pizza hut and in
this video we're going to build a roof
for our shipping container but it's not
going to be just a normal roof we're
going to do something experimental
something which i actually have never
seen before we're going to make a roof
on recycled plastic sheets no idea if
this makes sense or how to behave in the
long term but that's why we're going to
try it out we document it so it's a bit
like a living prototype so let's start
off with the most important thing first
getting the sheets okay so we want to
get our sheets from a precise plastic
workspace in case you don't know precise
plastic is a project that provides
knowledge and machines to recycle
plastic
and is all shared open source for free
so you can start your own plastic
recycling workspace it's kind of cool i
think the project is from denmark or
something i don't know i'll say check
out their website
and they have this cool map where you
can find all their different kind of
workspaces around the world and we need
sheets so we went to the map to find the
closest by sheepas workspace
in this case it's here in france so we
asked them to make our sheets
hi we are fab unit and we are going to
make roof tiles for project comp
we gonna make it from polypropylene
coming from industrial waste we are
going to make 28 of it
10 millimeters thick with cnc fish
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i think he's right there
right
oh
[Applause]
so here we have our sheets
they actually look super beautiful very
well finished and smooth a nice cnc
cutted edge to make sure we can overlap
them and it doesn't leak it's always
nice to see the flaky pattern to see the
yellow blending in the white it almost
looks like a stone you might wonder why
would you use recycled plastic in this
natural environment and i think in
general if you think about sustainable
living you have these two options you
use more natural materials but also more
recycled materials so using what's
already there and this is a test to see
how can we incorporate recycled plastics
and we do this more often we also have
some recycled bowls we're using or a
brick wall or a toilet seat just to test
out to see if we can realistically
incorporate it in our lives and how it
behaves over time so this is just
another one of those tests because we
don't know how it behaves with the sun
and the uv degradation
or the rain how it influences the sheets
so we're gonna build it test it out
analyze it keep track of it and document
it and in the end we might tell you guys
never build a plastic roof because it
doesn't make any sense or maybe it does
make sense and in that case it would be
kind of a useful application because
there are many roofs to build and a lot
of plastic goes into one sheet so this
is 10 kilogram so you can recycle quite
in bulk amounts so this is 280 kilograms
of plastic but before we're going to
install the roof we first need to build
a structure so we're going to do that
next
we're going to build a structure right
there in front of the kitchen and first
we're going to make some space and
prepare the ground
[Music]
so next we are going to build a piece of
metal to attach the wooden beams under
the plastic sheets to the metal frame of
the solar there
this is going to be a bit of cutting
welding drilling and painting so let's
start
hey
so
so
[Music]
okay
so the wood arrived we have a lot of
oiling sanding and cutting ahead of us
this will take us
a lot of hours quite a few days but for
you guys with me much quicker
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right so now we have all the wood
cut it as you can see it's kind of a lot
actually compared to the size of base
camp it's laying all around we have some
there some here
um but basically everything is now cut
it here you can see a lot of sawdust we
made and we're going to use that for our
compost toilet
and here the dark brown area is going to
be the floor
here the big beams are going to use as
pillars to hold up the roof
and over here this is going to be for
the roof
and as you can see we made a lot of cuts
in here
so it should all just be puzzled and fit
together
i'm not sure how it's actually gonna go
because all the wood is a little bit
bended and warped but i guess we're
gonna see next when we're actually gonna
assemble it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so we have a little issue here
this bean goes in this part of the
container laying here but in this side
as you can see it's a bit bended
so
we'll need to bend it down
easy
[Music]
does it work not working
we're going to try with a car jack to
bend it back
let's see
i don't know how it's going to go
but let's see
hmm
so
we finally cut a little piece here
because the cardiac didn't go i'm
bending this down it's quite impossible
by hand
so we got it and now it fits
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the floor structure is now ready
and it's all leveled straight
connected so we can walk on it
we added a few points to lift up the
wood and not the most elegant solution
but it works
and the beams itself
are clamped in this edge in the
container together with this one
next we're going to continue
building the structure to make sure
everything is straight and then we're
going to put in the floor paneling and
the roof paneling
darn it
oh
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
shoot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the roof is now up
next
the floor
[Music]
[Music]
the entire structure is now ready and
sturdy
and the frame on top should hold 28
sheets so yeah let's try
so we're now going to put up the sheets
on the roof
and there are a bit of difference in the
pattern so you have with white flakes
and more dark ones so we're gonna make a
nice pattern
and also we have
two different towels one our legs flush
on one side and have the overlap here
so we can put them together and the
middle ones have an overlap on both
sides
so we need to puzzle them together to
make sure it all fits
but yeah it's time to put on the roof
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
finish
[Music]
right yeah so structure is now ready and
this really felt like the last thing to
set up for base camp so we have a shady
place in the summer
not in the winter in the winter it
serves as a rain roof so now we have a
good comfortable setup here so we can
continue being on the land and do all
the other work we have to do and but
we're going to stop now because this is
the end of season 1 but we're going to
come back the 14th of april when season
2 starts so make sure to subscribe so
you don't forget to see that video
because we have a lot of big things we
still have to do alright so that was it
thanks for watching and see you in the
next season
you